[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dansions sortait la
nouvelle émission de tv 78 aujourd'hui
nous sommes à la maison elsa triolet
aragon à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines avec
guillaume roubaud kwasi bonjour je vous
êtes le directeur du site
exactement alors le moulin de villeneuve
là où nous sommes c'est là où l'on
habité et louis aragon et elsa triolet
c'est un lieu qui est un petit peu
restée figée dans le temps à l'intérieur
les objets sont d'époque
c'était une volonté de votre part en
réalité c'est une volonté du couple et
plus précisément d'aragon puisque c'est
lui qui décide à la fin des années 1970
de donner cette maison à la nation
française c'est sa formule et le legs
d'accepter en 1984 et donc quand la
maison ouvre au public en 1994
eh bien on peut découvrir la partie qui
l'ont habité qui est resté effectivement
comme elle l'a été quand il est quand il
était dense dans cette maison là c'est à
dire que quand vous vous promenez à
l'intérieur de la maison
vous pouvez tomber sur bien la cuisine
telle qu'elle était avec encore
d'ailleurs un réfrigérateur de la marque
frigidaire voilà tout est resté comme ça
où vous pouvez tomber aussi sur la
cravate d'aragon on a l'impression que
qui va arriver où qu'ils vont arriver
l'un et l'autre d'un moment à l'autre et
il ya beaucoup aussi d'artistes qui sont
venus ici pour les voir en tant
qu'artiste les rencontrer ils ont laissé
des oeuvres qu'est ce qu'on peut voir
dans la maison évidemment on ne voit pas
qu un frigidaire dans cette maison c'est
vrai qu'on puisse dire puisque aragon
était un écrivain bien sûr mais est apte
à triolet ou également mais il est tous
les deux très lié à d'autres écrivains
mais aussi à des artistes à des
plasticiens depuis longtemps et donc
beaucoup sont venus ici et beaucoup
donné des oeuvres aux couples et donc
dans la maison quand vous allez dans la
cuisine
vous avez par exemple une oeuvre
originale de fernand léger quand vous
poussez un peu plus loin vous pouvez
tomber sur plusieurs oeuvres de picasso
et puis il ya également des oeuvres
d'autres d'autres d'autres artistes
comme fuseront comme tasted ski comme
mia et donc il ya vraiment une grande
variété d'artistes qui sont explosé à
l'intérieur de la maison
ces oeuvres ne sont pas exposés comme si
c'était pour des visiteurs ils sont
exposés parce que quand il habitait là
et bien les oeuvres de leurs amis
étaient à leurs côtés il ya vraiment une
volonté de nous montrer aux visiteurs
comment c'était à l'époque et comme
comme une ville est en fait exactement
voilà c
aussi vous entriez chez aragon et chez
elsa triolet et donc chez eux c'est
aussi le jardin le grand parc c'était un
lieu d'inspiration pour eux aujourd'hui
on peut le visiter
alors il se trouve que elsa triolet êtes
une femme de la ville de moscou voyait
et arabes dans la région parisienne et
elle dit à sa soeur à un moment j'avais
manqué la nature et elle découvre ici
dans le var de saint-arnoult la faune la
flore tout autant d'éléments qu'elle
qu'elle connaissait mal est donc
évidemment un jardin fait vraiment
partie de la maison au sens large du
terme
c'est elsa triolet elle même qui était
architecte de formation qui a dessiné
les dessins et les parcours pendant les
chemins du parc
donc c'est vraiment parti de la maison
et puis de toute façon ils sont tous les
deux enterrés ici dans le parc de la
maison donc évidemment le parc est
ouvert à la visite
et donc c'est on peut aussi aller se
recueillir sur les tombes exactement la
tombée et peut-être
peut-être visiter de cette manière elle
peut accueillir des visiteurs et quand
on s'approche de la tombe
on a installé là une sarabande de bach
qui est jouée par rostropovitch pourquoi
parce que rostropovitch le grand
violoncelliste est venu lui-même ici
jouer sur la tombe d'elle à triolet
cette sarabande de bach qu'on diffuse
qu'on diffuse aujourd'hui c'est aussi un
lieu d'exposition un lieu de création
artistique c'était une volonté de louis
aragon si je me trompe furtivement quand
vous êtes en couple mais non mais je
vous en prie quand aragon l'ex cette
maison à la nation française son souhait
est de faire de ce lieu un lieu de
mémoire donc consacrer à leurs oeuvres à
leur vie donc cette première c'est la
première dimension qu'on a évoqué mais
il souhaite aussi en faire un centre de
recherche
c'est pour ça que ici nous avons des
chercheurs qui peuvent consulter les
ouvrages de la bibliothèque d'aragon il
ya triolet il ya plus de trente mille
ouvrages qui sont présents dans la
maison des dédicaces différents aspects
et puis également un centre de création
faut bien mesurer que aragon comme elsa
triolet ont tous les deux beaucoup aidé
toute leur vie était aidée de vous deux
jeunes créateurs ont toujours été
sensible aux questions plastique est
donc aujourd'hui encore on prolonge cet
été ce prix d'aragon les attribue au
lait en organisant des expositions trois
expositions chaque année et dans le parc
par ailleurs et bien il y à des
sculptures contemporaines qui ont été
déposés offerte laisser laissé en dépôt
ou offertes à la maison les à triolet
aragon et qui équivaut maintenant horn
hors de son parc
alors en ce moment en parlant des
expositions jusqu'au 30 novembre une
exposition consacrée à bernard prat et à
nakache
pourquoi avoir fait cette exposition
bien on est vraiment dans l'esprit de ce
qu'on souhaite ici donc l'ouverture en
direction de l'art contemporain
et puis évidemment il y avait un clin
d'oeil parce que bernard prat et nakache
sont un couple est évidemment dans une
maison de couple d'artistes est toujours
intéressante pour nous d'accueillir un
couple de créateurs et donc ils
présentent leurs oeuvres d'une part ici
derrière les offres de bernard prat et
puis
là bas dans le pavillon il ya les
oeuvres d'anne à cash merci beaucoup et
guillaume robot kwasi nous avoir
accueillis aujourd'hui je vous en prie
merci à vous merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve bientôt pour
de nouvelles idées de sorties dans les
yvelines
[Musique]